bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
petite vidéo analyse de trailer une
nouvelle bande-annonce dédiée à la série
secretin vision vient de sortir et je me
suis dit que ce serait sympa de faire
pourquoi pas une petite coupure vu que
je suis actuellement en train de
travailler sur de la grosse vidéo
surtout qu'en plus je m'en rends compte
malgré quelques théories dédiées à the
marvels on a jamais vraiment parlé de
Secret Invasion enfin du moins on n'a
pas parlé du premier trailer du coup
voilà il est temps de rectifier ça
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner pour ne
pas louper les prochaines grosses vidéos
sur ce si vous êtes prêts on y va bon
tout d'abord je pense que vous l'avez
compris mais la série secret in vision
prévue pour le 21 juin va nous adapter
le célèbre événement des comics du même
nom l'invasion secrète dans les comics
c'est tout d'abord une représentation de
la nature même du peuple scroll qui
implémente les planètes de leur
congénère pour en prendre le contrôle
grâce à leur pouvoir de métamorphose
mais plus que ça encore c'est également
une réponse au conflit sans fin opposant
les Scrolls à leurs ennemis les cris en
fait dans comics la terre est considérée
comme un lieu hyper stratégique tout
simplement car elle est située à un
carrefour interstellaire et c'est
quelque chose que convoite les Scrolls
notamment pour contrecarrer leurs
ennemis l'écrit qui eux aussi convoquent
cette dernière tout ça là c'est la base
de Secret Invasion bien évidemment pour
le MCU ils vont réadapter la chose et
l'ajuster pour que cela colle à
l'univers et que cela soit beaucoup plus
digeste normalement si crazy invasion
c'est l'invasion de l'Empire scroll
lui-même à travers toute la terre mais
ici cela semble différent dans le MCU
nous n'avons pas encore de véritables
empires scroll à proprement parler nous
avons seulement ceux qui ont été sauvés
par Nick Fiori et Carol denverse durant
le film Captain Marvel et justement à
cette époque car je rappelle que Captain
Marvel se déroulait dans les années 90
Nick Fiori face à Talos lui promettait
de lui trouver une maison pour lui et
son peuple et par conséquent que les
Scrolls ne seraient que de passage sur
terre néanmoins bien c'est là que le
véritable problème fait surface Nick
Fiori ne semble pas avoir tenu sa
promesse et pour cause la Terre a été
sujet à de nombreux conflits dans les
décennies suivantes et de l'autre côté
nous n'avons aucune information
concernant Captain Marvel qui souhaitait
remettre de l'ordre dans l'empire cri
permettant au passage au scroll de
retrouver la liberté du coup c'est là
que cela devient intéressant comme
déclaré par quelques informations une
faction scroll issue de se sauver durant
les événements liés au film Captain
Marvel on non juste marre d'attendre et
de vivre en cachette cela fait près de
30 ans qu'ils se sont investis dans
l'ombre sur Terre en attendant que Nick
Fiori et Carol denverse leur trouve une
maison une maison qui n'arrive toujours
pas et en plus de cela depuis les
événements d'Avengers Infinity war Nick
Fiori est déclaré comme mort donc la
solution est simple étant donné tout le
temps qu'ils ont passé sur terre est-ce
qu'il ne serait pas temps pour les
Scrubs de revendiquer cette dernière
dans l'ombre pour relancer leur empire
c'est là le point pertinent et qui
annonce la dangerosité prévue par la
série Les Scrubs depuis 30 ans ont
appréhendé la vie humaine et de par leur
relation avec Nick Fiori ont pu
s'investir en interne notamment grâce au
SHIELD donc il connaît sous le terrain
il connaissent les enjeux politiques il
connaissent les entités puissantes et ce
n'est pas du tout une invasion
extraterrestre comme il les proposait
dans les comics bon maintenant essayons
de nous focaliser un petit peu plus sur
les trailers et voyons s'il y a des
détails ou des éléments intéressants qui
méritent d'être soulignés déjà nous
sommes face à un Nick Fiori en train de
revenir de l'espace comme il nous avait
été montré dans Spider-Man far from home
il sait d'ailleurs ce qu'il se passe sur
Terre ce qui veut dire pour moi que
Marvel studio a opéré comme dans les
comics ou Nick Fiori était au courant de
l'invasion scroll car un scroll
justement avait tenté de le berner et de
le confronter avant de lui révéler la
fameuse invasion par la suite nous
voyons plusieurs plans de ville connu
comme Moscou par exemple avec notamment
gravik le leader de la faction scroll
rebelle en train de causer une explosion
cela traduit complètement l'idée de
l'invasion scroll à travers toute la
planète il nous sera d'ailleurs révélé
que l'intrigue s'étendra également en
France comme nous le montre ce journal
parlant des Avengers ensuite nous allons
faire face à l'intégration également de
nouveaux personnages comme Sonia Falls
worth qui accueille Nick Fiori chez elle
et l'accompagne dans sa quête alors fact
intéressant Sonia semble être un
personnage complètement inédit néanmoins
d'après son visuel et plus
particulièrement son nom Falls worth
cette dernière semble quand même relier
à un personnage plutôt célèbre des
comics Union Jack un jack pour faire
simple c'est un noble qui agit en tant
qu'agent secret britannique et son titre
va passer de père en fils dans sa
famille dont le nom est folle sworth
pour le MCU Sonia semble être la
représentation moderne d'Union Jack ou
du moins possède son héritage en étant
sa descendante déjà Fiori est un agent
secret donc sa liaison avec cette
dernière pourrait s'expliquer facilement
mais de plus nous sommes témoins de la
richesse de Sonia de par ses vêtements
ou encore son appartement tout ce côté
noble en gros mais surtout nous la
retrouvons dans un plan avec une sorte
de poignard et c'est un élément fort car
union jack est un héros dont l'arme de
prédilection est un poignard en acier
d'ailleurs si nous respectons le l'or
Union Jack et britannique dont cela
sous-entendrait que l'Angleterre est
également de la partie dans la série
parmi les nouveaux personnages nous
avons également la confirmation de
l'identité du protagoniste que va
incarner Emilia Clarke il s'agit de Guya
la fille de Talos alors c'est
intéressant car personnellement je pense
que cette dernière jouera sur les deux
tableaux et effectivement son arrivée
sur Terre s'est effectué quand elle
était encore très jeune par conséquent
cela veut dire que pendant 30 ans elle a
grandi et vécu en cachette dans l'ombre
des humains ce qui du coup très durer
complètement pour moi son envie de
s'émanciper de cette vie néanmoins dans
la fille de Talos et ayant partagé avec
Mick Fiori cela m'étonnerait qu'elle
soit quand même une méchante mais dans
tous les cas ces dernières sera
principal Emilia Clarke est un peu la
star du casting parmi les nouveaux
arrivants donc on se doute qu'elle aura
un grand rôle à jouer et enfin
j'aimerais m'attarder sur un plan que je
trouve très sympa c'est le moment où tu
as l'eau se s’entretient avec gravy que
le chef de la facture scroll si nous
regardons dans le fond du plan nous
pouvons voir des banderoles à l'effigie
de personnage important de l'histoire de
l'humanité et en dessous de chacun est
écrit les visages de la liberté c'est un
détail que je trouve très sympa car il
permet de nous démontrer l'intention des
scrolls il souhaite retrouver la liberté
il souhaite avoir leur monde et vivre à
visage découvert tout comme les
personnages qui ont marqué l'histoire
greavi que pourrait devenir ce visage de
la liberté dont a besoin les Scrolls et
en parlant de Grey vie tiens un certain
plan du trailer nous montre que ce
dernier semble différent de ses
congénères nous le voyons utiliser des
pouvoirs encore jamais vu parmi le
peuple scroll et ça c'est une référence
au comics greavi que semble être un
super scroll soit un scroll qui a été
génétiquement modifié en s'inspirant de
l'ADN d'autres personnages et plus
exactement d'autres héros pour assimiler
leur pouvoir c'est un phénomène que
d'ailleurs les Illuminati devront faire
face dans les comics après avoir été
kidnappées par l'Empire scroll ces
derniers ont étudié et récolté l'ADN de
nos héros pour que leur soldats et les
mêmes pouvoirs que leurs ennemis pour le
MCU c'est assez difficile à expliquer
comment greavy aurait atteint ce stade
d'évolution mais personnellement je me
dis qu'étant donné que les Scrolls sont
intimement liés au SHIELD et que
d'ailleurs le dahmedge Control est aussi
de retour dameche control qui possède
énormément de savoir relier au super
héros ou autre spécimens ou armement
comme démontré dans les précédentes
production de Marvel et bien par rapport
à tout ça je me dis que greavi aurait pu
obtenir de l'ADN ou d'autres savoir lui
permettant de se développer et d'évoluer
grâce à ça mais voilà cela reste de la
petite théorie dans tous les cas Nick
Fiori devra s'engager seul dans ce
conflit déjà car il ne pourra plus faire
confiance en personne à cause de
l'invasion mais surtout car il devra
faire face à ses propres échecs si ce
dernier avait tenu sa promesse
l'invasion scroll n'aurait jamais eu
lieu
et voilà je pense que l'on va s'arrêter
là c'était une petite vidéo chill en
attendant donc n'hésitez pas à laisser
un petit pouce bleu un commentaire et
surtout à vous abonner car ce week-end
je vous sors une grosse vidéo d'une
heure effectivement c'est la sortie d'un
nouveau pourquoi sont-ils réunis et on
va s'attaquer à une mastodonte de
l'univers Marvel donc soyez au
rendez-vous sur ce les amis merci
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo cet état
rock que le lion heart soit avec vous
allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]